hello I'm Anne McElroy and welcome to
the intelligence squared podcast teamed
up this week with economist radio you
can find out about intelligence squared
podcasts and live events at intelligence
squared comm my guest is Jordan Peterson
a clinical psychologist and professor at
the University of Toronto
he's just written 12 rules for life an
antidote to chaos rule number one is
stand up straight with your shoulders
back rule number four compare yourself
to who you were yesterday not to who
someone else is today rule number six
set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world I've already
felt that one and rule number twelve pet
a cat when you encounter one on the
street so far so modern folksy but
Peterson is best known these days as a
scourge of much modern liberal thinking
a stance that's brought him at last
following of fans and detractors it all
began when beyond the lecture hall
Peterson took to answering questions in
an online forum
he says his procrastination induced
musings hit a nerve they certainly did
he now has hundreds of thousands of
followers on social media his YouTube
channel has over a million subscribers
with videos such as identity politics
and the Marxist lie of white privilege
and the psychological significance of
the biblical stories he wants to bring
order to a world of chaos
Jordan Peterson welcome thanks very much
for the invitation why do you think that
your book twelve rules for life on the
bestseller lists already and the online
videos with it have struck such a chord
what's at site-geist because I'm firmly
on the side of my viewers and readers
and I'm doing everything I can to help
them understand how to live responsible
and meaningful lives and that there's a
and that there's a conjunction between
those two issues of responsibility and
meaning
that hasn't been addressed properly in
our culture for a long time and when you
say your viewers and readers are you
thinking here of a specific group of
people are these targeted on a
particular group no no I wouldn't say so
I have more male viewers online but on
YouTube the standard viewer is male so
it isn't obvious that that's a
consequence of my philosophy let's say
more than an artifact of the technology
I think that male activity is viewed
with far more skepticism than is
warranted at the moment and that's
certainly a problem and that's part of
the viewpoint that assumes that what our
culture is is best construed as
oppressive patriarchy of some sort and
that any activity within that is to be
regard regarded as a manifestation of
that proclivity towards tyranny which is
an absolutely appalling viewpoint in my
estimation and I make that make that
what would you call it opinion quite
clear but for me most of this is a
matter of psychological endeavor not
political endeavor we might come back on
the proclivity towards tyranny later on
and how that relates to how you see this
argument but just on your interest in
young men particularly in in the young
male in Western societies you often talk
beyond that but mainly I think that's
your focus wouldn't be fair to say that
your focus is on how men feel in
societies and where no their honor I
don't think that that is my focus I
think that my focus is the focus that
you'd expect from a clinical
psychologist and an educator which is to
help individuals regardless of their
group identity live better lives I think
the fact that what I mean being doing is
being construed in that manner is a
consequence of the absolutely
overwhelming influence of identity
politics and and post-modernism for that
matter on our political and
philosophical discourse what I'm doing
is constantly being viewed as a
manifestation of identity politics and
so people talk about my particular
attraction for young white men it's like
sorry not true
there's
there's virtually no evidence for that
the audience's that come to see me are
and I hate to even categorize them in
this manner because it's part of playing
the same game but very diverse
ethnically and and and with regards to
gender as well so the problem is is that
the way that our discourse is framed
right now it's impossible to avoid being
shunted into an identity politics box
and I think that that's I think that
there's nothing about that that isn't
reprehensible you said I mean I really
interested in point in exploring what
you know where you're starting for but
you sound isn't quite angry what do you
feel like well I'm I'm I'm appalled at
the role the universities have played in
this to to to form to to to have
influenced the culture so that this is
the manner in which our discourse is
conducted that the primary issue is
which group is what you're saying
targeted towards like my group why what
I'm saying isn't targeted towards groups
in fact it's precisely construed as an
antidote to the idea that your message
should be targeted as group at groups
I'm interested in the individual and and
it also makes sense given my background
first of all you met professors so I
teach individual students and second of
all and perhaps not in that order I'm a
clinical psychologist not a sociologist
and not a politician
none of that concentrating on the
development of the individual and when I
go do my talks I have thousands of
people coming to my talks and I meet I
meet thousands of people as a
consequence of doing that personally and
none of them talk to me about politics
all of them say the same thing they've
been watching my lectures online or
they've been reading my book they were
in a dark place in their life they've
been trying to adopt personal
responsibility and a vision for the
future and as a constant and and to tell
the truth to the degree that they can to
take responsibility for their own
behavior and to improve their lives of
their families and their communities and
because of doing that things are much
better for them and that's the story I'm
interested that you chose a self-help
kind of trip here with the book the
rules for for life takes us back to
Samuel smiles and Victorians sort of
self-help manuals in some senses in a
tradition but you're someone who doesn't
like to be told what
and you think you know a lot of
modernity is kind of telling a bit
finger-wagging or telling people what to
do so why would you accept your rules
would you accept Jordan Peterson's rules
if you weren't Jordan Peterson oh good
good point yeah well you know you you
might also ask in some sense how I can
get away with that because you know for
example last year I did a series of
lectures on the Bible on on on the on
Genesis and it's very easy to make that
sort of thing into a finger-wagging
morality but I'm not not including
myself in the list of people who need
improvement I'm not talking from a
pinnacle downwards to my audience you
know I'm I'm stating a fairly blunt fact
which is that we have plenty of we have
plenty of tragedy and malevolence to
contend with in the confines of our life
and we need to figure out how to deal
with that properly without becoming
bitter and cruel and resentful and these
rules are guidelines to help people
avoid those pitfalls rather than finger
wagging moral injunctions designed to
make them feel guilty and so that's why
the elections are attractive because
that that kind of top-down morality is
actually absent from them and one view
of this large popularity that you are
enjoying it at the moment the moment if
you like that you wouldn't be the moment
is that you captured a kind of space
between what many people think and what
they're being told to think does that
ring a bell with you and do you think
that's a fair description is that
something your graph aiming to do well I
think that people are have a sense that
again that the manner in which our
public discourse is being conducted has
as tremendous danger and the danger is
essentially the elevation of the
collective over the individual and that
that poses a danger both on the left and
on the right and I think that by
appealing to the notion of individual
sovereignty which I would say is the
primary would you say it's the meta
message behind all of the things that
I've been writing about that people find
that to be a great relief even though
what I'm asking them to do is to bear
more responsibility for what they do
then they might typically be inclined to
and so but it's all it's you see look I
I'm facing some of the issues that that
people confront in their lives very
squarely I believe the the fundamental
religious truth of the idea that life is
suffering it's suffering because we're
mortal and fragile and because we're
also subject to malevolence at our own
hands into that at at the hands of
others it's a it's a constant
existential problem and that can make
you bitter and can make you hopeless and
nihilistic and depressed and anxious and
pro and likely to abuse substances
various sorts as a medication or an
escape
it can augur you in in in a very large
number of ways and I'm suggesting to
people that there is a way out of that
and the way out is to confront that
forthrightly and to adopt responsibility
in your own life and to try to make the
world a better place and that it's
necessary to do that and that if you
don't do that that things go badly and
it's a relief to people to hear that
because they know it they already know
it so get a grip on yourself well it's
it's more find something in your life
that's so worthwhile doing that the fact
that you're going to suffer is
justifiable but if that something a
value were for instance or someone to
decide that they are a radical feminists
or a radical trans campaigner that would
be something of great value in their
lives but these are not positions that I
think you think have been if you do not
have great value in their life because
what they're doing is abdicating their
personal responsibility to live by their
own truth let's say to adherence to an
ideology and I'm not a fan of ideologies
I think they're unbelievably dangerous
and I don't really care whether they're
on the left or the right so to be a
feminist or a trans activist or to adopt
that that group fostered view of the
world
I think is generally an a mistake and I
don't think it does people any good not
usually and it also allows them to adopt
and and this is something else that's
very very gone very wrong with our
political discourse is that it allows
people to adopt and unearned an unearned
sense of moral superiority and also of
omniscient knowledge because in India
all
she offers you that and there's just
nothing in that that that's helpful
so what you have right mints but then
what you have isn't an ideology or no
it's not an easy ology and there isn't a
strong collection of ideas in a sense
always an ideal no it's not it's not and
it's a mistake to think that way because
all that means is that the way that you
construe the world is a battleground
between different ideologies and if an
ideologies is only that which serves a
power elite let's say which is part of
the postmodern Neel Marxist construal
then all it ever is is a battle of
opinions and there's nothing underneath
that and it's all power and and that's
just not an appropriate way of looking
at the world first of all there's lots
of forces at play that aren't mere power
competence is one of them assuming that
there are some things that are
worthwhile doing and then with regards
to ideology I wrote a book about that
the first book I wrote is called maps of
meaning and it's a it's a description of
the relationship between archetypal or
mythological thinking proper religious
thinking I would say and the parasitical
structures that emerge from that which
are basically ideologies and they can be
technically differentiated what do you
make of liberalism
I would consider myself a classic
liberal you would consider yourself oh
yes yes although Jesus also has beliefs
attached right it comes out of a
tradition of evolution of beliefs but
there also there is also a radical
liberalism which feeds into feminism
which believes that progress is a better
thing than the lack of progress I really
the economist is founded on those basics
and that people can argue about what
they want to to take or leave but do you
include then liberalism as one of the
isms that you would say is in crisis at
the moment always got itself into well
well it depends to some degree as you
pointed out on how you define liberalism
but one of the things that I like about
the classic liberal take on the world
which which I and to which I think we
owe
Britain a great debt of gratitude for
developing perhaps more particularly
than any other country is that the
individuals is to be regarded as the
sovereign entity in the political
understanding but that's not really a
political claim
it's a claim that underlies politics
it's actually a theological claim it's
derived from the judeo-christian
tradition and because India
judeo-christian tradition the suffering
individual is the sovereign entity and
we established a political system based
on that metaphysical axiom and so I
would say that to the degree that
liberalism acts out the idea of the
sovereignty of the individual it's not
an ism it's it's not a political stance
it's far deeper than that what it's
predicated on and the the idea of the
sovereignty of the individual is an idea
that emerged with great difficulty over
tens of thousands of years or longer
than that has an immense developmental
history that radically predates let's
say the Enlightenment or or any
articulated political beliefs it's far
deeper notion than anything that can be
encapsulated politically but if we look
at the great some of the great classic
liberals of the 19th century and we look
back to male for example you have
individual liberty very strongly in
there from Locke onwards a sort of the
sense of the sovereignty and no one from
the monarch down has it has the right to
unfair sovereignty another man or a
woman but you also have a strongly kind
of progressive sense that that develops
as liberalism develops and takes you
towards women's franchise towards
actually in Mills case a fairly
out-there feminism if Jess mill was
sitting here instead of me would you be
seeing eye to eye on whether that was a
good idea well again I think it depends
on what what you mean by feminism I mean
the idea that it would be a good thing
for the world to arrange itself so that
the talents of women were as available
to use by the collective let's say by
the group or by society as the talents
of men then obviously that's all for the
good I don't have any problem with that
whatsoever because talents in short
supply and and it's a foolish society
that wastes that no matter where it
manifests itself racial divisions or
ethnic divisions or any of that equality
of opportunity I can't see how you can
be a sensible person and nor do women
have opportunity so we do women have
equality of opportunity than broadly
across Western societies
compared to what
look compared to not having equality
vote compared to a hundred years ago yes
compared to fifty years ago yes compared
to most places in the world throughout
history yes compared to a hypothetical
ideal no but I'm very very good idea or
a bad idea well it depends on how you
define equality if you define it as
equality of outcome then it's a
catastrophic ideal see this is something
to you know one of the things I've been
struggling with recently is the idea of
boundaries let's say we know absolutely
and and this is relative to you relevant
to your question zone progressivism we
know that the Left can go too far and we
know that the right can go too far I
mean I would say that's the abject
lesson of the 20th century both can go
too far and we kind of know when the
right goes too far we probably think the
right goes too far if you had to boil it
down to one thing when people start
making claims of racial or ethnic
superiority that seems to be the marker
but we don't know when the Left goes too
far and the left to be frank about it
isn't very careful about differentiating
itself into those who are pursuing a
reasonable progressive agenda and those
who have seriously gone too far and I
would say that when people push an
equality of outcome agenda they've gone
too far even though it's not as
blatantly horrifying let's say as claims
of ethnic or racial superiority the
consequences of playing that idea out in
the world are seriously not good but
surely they are you know they're two
kind of door stops it's the far ends of
the arguments I mean very few people I
think on the left and there would be
some who would advocate for absolute
equality of outcome and everything it
would take to achieve not so clear
dissimilar so there may be lots of
things that are wrong both on the left
and on the right that don't involve the
right being overtly racist and the left
wanting absolute equality of outcome
it's a space surely in the middle that
matters and that's why I suppose people
feel that sometimes your argument is
also sort of its driving towards picking
the fight rather than liberalism would I
suppose encourage you to take the best
and we can have the argument about
what's the best and what's the worst of
every
it's in between no I think that the the
left poses a far greater danger than
your analysis suggests I certainly see
this in the universities and the the
drum is being beat very very hard
perhaps not so much here but in North
America for equality of opportunity or
equality of outcome under the rubric of
equity and equity is essentially a
doctrine that Foster's the notion that
equality of outcome is not only
desirable but should be pursued as an an
object or as an explicit aspect of
public policy the idea being that if the
there aren't there is an equivalent
representation of all possible groups at
all possible levels of all possible
hierarchies that that indicates a
tyrannical prejudice that needs to be
rooted out and that's having an
absolutely pernicious effect on on
institutions especially educational
institutions in North America that's not
a and it's an increasingly widespread
view and I think it poses far more
danger than is anything is it possible
that views become more attractive when
something is dissatisfied and when
aspirations have not been met which are
reasonable aspirations to have and you
can then say that the answers are wrong
or that they oh but say if this is such
a popular view to cite your example on
campuses in North America it may be that
there's something out there that
existing society has not satisfied what
hasn't satisfied the ever-present human
tendency towards envy and resentment
that's for sure that's always driving it
not at all but it's a tremendous amount
of what's driving it and a lack of
absolute lack of gratitude for what
we've managed to accomplish and what we
have in front of us I mean unfairness
does that figure well unfairness is a
very ill-defined term I mean it's not so
obvious either it's not so obvious
what's fair so for example you know I
got embroiled in a dispute the last time
I was in you in the UK about the issue
of the gender pay gap and you know from
from a social science perspective the
idea of the gender pay gap is it's it's
it's so poorly formulated that it's
almost staggering to me that people can
even conceptualize it in this manner
it's not a univariate problem it's a
multivariate problem men and women don't
make breakage
and then we can get you know not only
could we we have to and and we can't
assume that just because in all
situations women don't make as much
money as men although there are some
situations in which the reverse is true
by the way that the reason for that is
prejudice and depression there's many
reasons for it one reason so there's a
book by wit by Warren Farrell for
example called why men make more and he
outlines like 42 reasons why men make
more money than women one of them is
that men are much more likely to take
dangerous occupations not at 42 and then
some of the reasons but perhaps just
start by talking a bit more about gender
with you that unsure on fraught
territory always seems to go up do you
agree with people who hold that broadly
gender is a social consequences for STUV
all that's an axiomatic pronouncement
rather than a consequence of the
analysis of the empirical data and I
mean what do you mean a social construct
genitalia aren't a social construct
differences in height aren't a social
construct difference is what we did you
said Italia is to an extent constructed
it well because there's environmental
and and cultural effects on anything
that's complex and that's certainly the
case and differentiating what those are
is a very difficult thing to do but the
psychometric work on that has already
been done and done well and when I what
do you mean that a second metric look I
mean psychologists in particular have
spent 40 years sorting out an
empirically derived model of personality
that's the Big Five model which is well
accepted among personality psychologists
in the mainstream most of who lean left
by the way by an overwhelming majority
so there's no right that might be five
yeah but it's but one of the things
that's interesting about the taxonomy is
that it was a theoretically derived it's
purely a consequence of statistical
analysis and so I'm not sure where
that's taking us so well how far gender
is socially constructed okay so for the
first thing to do is to figure out what
the parameters are when you talk about
something like gender so the parameters
are say parameters of temperament
because you said well we're not going to
talk about by all
we're going to talk about what's derived
from that so we might say temperament
okay so we know the temporary mental
dimensions we know that they differ
between men and women and they differ
cross-culturally but more importantly
this is the crucial distinction well we
don't know because I mean I'm just
looking at a piece of recent research on
the brain which concludes the Ranaut's
two types of brain in there are there
are others who did the research it's the
new scientists construe there's no such
thing as the male or female brain just
so you know what you yeah baby no nobody
who has any sense would ever claim if
there was a male and female brain ok
these differences aren't absolute what
do you want so should we just take that
as a question you want to engage that
question on two types of brain and then
we can be a bit clearer well there are
nice types of brain and men and women
are more the same by personality than
they are different by a substantial
margin there's more similarities than
differences if there's more similarity
than difference but that doesn't mean
the differences are irrelevant so let me
give you an example so if you pick two
people at random out of the population
and had to guess which who is more
aggressive and you guessed the man you'd
be right 60 percent of the time that's
about the magnitude of the difference
between men and women that's six sixty
forties and that's exactly right less
but but but and this is where things get
more sophisticated all right so then
imagine that you had to pick the one in
a hundred most aggressive person and put
them in jail which is what we do they're
all men so even though at the midpoint
the difference between men and women
isn't that extreme at the extremes the
difference is extraordinary and most of
the activity are much of the activity in
complex situations happens at the
extremes so men are more interested in
things than women are and women are more
interested in people than men are on
average and those differences are
largest in Scandinavia by the way so
there's no evidence that there
socio-culturally constructed and one of
the consequences of that is is that if
you leave men and women to make free
choices well let's put aside that
Scandinavia is no choice it's not just
one country that has lots of different
cultural political differences sure but
the point is is that and this is the
fundamental point is that the more
egalitarian the country the bigger the
differences between men and women the
bigger I have no idea how one could
possibly you rain
you rank order countries by their
socio-cultural policies from egalitarian
to non egalitarian and then you look at
the magnitude at the differences in
temperament in men and women in those
countries and you do those on your
definition of temperament but this but
there isn't a definition of temperament
that exists that valid outside of the
psychometric community locked into a
particular definition within what you
call the psychometric community and
other people may simply say look I
experienced the world very differently
and I have evidence from my dealings
whether I'm a man whether I'm a woman
whether I'm looking at how we get along
together and what we do to improve
matters that doesn't conform to that you
know the question is then what is the
evidence the fact that someone has a
lien about it isn't relevant you have a
relevant issue is whether what the
evidence suggests unless you're willing
to throw out the scientific enterprise
which I wouldn't recommend not I'm
certainly not doing that but I do think
there to pin it to a narrow definition
of psychometric test not merit it's five
dimensional it's not narrow the whole
world only has four dimensions five
dimensional model is actually
extraordinarily sophisticated it's got
four dimensions and then weave into five
that's magic
well you have five dimensions there's
many multi-dimensional spaces but
reality itself has four dimensions and
we there's plenty of complexities come
back to you I mean you're a bit you know
absolutely come back to evidence but
also to what you make of the evidence
because Trading's well all I make of the
evidence is moral reasons for gender
difference so what do we then do with
this let's say that we decide that there
are differences and we can argue whether
that's about the average I mean who is
the average woman am i the average woman
mm-hmm
in some ways probably in other ways okay
good good to know
so what do we do with it so it takes us
into this an argument about what
progress should look like and the gender
pay gap was a good example of that as
you say lots of different ways of
describing it lots of different
approaches to dealing with it the
challenge to you would still be I think
do you think that situation that we have
is broadly fair in workplaces and that
women are self-selecting out of progress
up the paid chain rather than being to
an extent under
pressure of child-rearing that is not
probably accounted for or that they're
not properly helped with is it really
all about their decision or might
structures not play a role here when
doesn't hold structures defeating this
right no no no what you have to be
completely mad is to reduce the whole
thing to gender and to assume that it's
a consequence of oppression there's
multiple factors at play and prejudice
is one of them the question is to what
degree prejudice or an arbitrary
categorization let's say and and the
lack of provision of opportunities for
women is contributing to the pay gap and
what to what degree other factors are
contributing so there's other factors
like I said already men are much more
likely to do dangerous jobs they're also
more likely to do jobs that scale so for
example because women are more
interested in people on average than men
are they tend to work in people oriented
enterprises and those are hard to scale
and because you can't scale them it's
harder to multiply the income men are
likely more likely to move than women
are men are more likely to take on trade
positions they're more likely to work
with heavy machinery they're more likely
to work outside all of these things add
today if you catch that up to them if
you if you took out working with heavy
machinery which some women do but more
we can say right more men will and will
elect to do that there's quite a lot of
things in there where there being not
you know we're all nudge throughout our
life to to certain choices we don't have
to accept the nudge but then would you
accept that women have lacked
opportunities that they've liked that
nudge has not operated in the same way
so but you to say oh well they end over
what time spa you can choose cheesy
tights and say 100 years if you like
well the time span the point is are
women in a sense already being going
through it all going through a number of
gates in in in life and wider than
others complicated I mean I think men
men were directed down narrow pathways
in ways that women weren't so for
example they were much more likely to be
conscripted into Wars for example which
actually happens to be a non-trivial
phenomena because it resulted in the
deaths and ended and and the demolition
of many men and so both both sexes are
subject to the arbitrary strictures of
culture and perhaps you
argue that women had the worst time of
it although it's not that easy an
argument to make I would say that the
extra pressures of child-rearing and the
inevitability of pregnancy played a very
large role in that and we didn't deal
with that effectively till 1960 and so
one of the things that I really don't
like about the men women were oppressed
by men throughout history narrative is
the fact that both men and women were
terribly oppressed by nature throughout
history and that's not being factored
into the equation and I think that what
men and women did for most of history
the decent ones anyways was team up and
partner up and try to make life the
least amount of miserable for both and
yet we read this narrative backwards and
we say well the reason that men and
women weren't operating equally in the
socio-cultural landscape was because men
were oppressing them it's like sorry no
that accounts for a tiny fraction of it
or some proportion of it but it had much
more to do with the fact that everyone
was poor and miserable and that women
were locked into a reproductive cycle
from which they had no practical escape
I mean we didn't fix that till the 60s
what might irritate some working women
indeed some women whether they work or
not is you you can either sort of look
at something like the gender pay gap and
sort of pick apart how difficult it is
or you could say well that's let's try
to to fix this and let's have an
intelligent argument about how we best
fix this thing and the argument that
women are self-selecting out of the
workplace actually becomes you know
becomes a bit of a roadblock but women
do self-select out of the workplace all
the time well if you look at the legal
profession that's that's absolutely
crystal clear women are over represented
at the lower ends of the legal
profession but they stop they stop
operating at the high ends in their 30s
and it happens in all sorts of
professions and there's good reason for
it
I mean well because women in their late
20s tend to decide that they don't want
to work 80 hours a week they would
rather have a family and devote some
time to that which is a perfectly
reasonable thing to do another possibly
reasonable thing to do is for the
child-rearing roles of men and women to
come more into balance then allowing
with some trade-offs life being
imperfect allowing women to come back
earlier
assuming that you put you know you put
it on the window no no not at all that's
not a fair characterization in the least
your argument is predicated on the idea
that the advantage to women isn't coming
back to the workplace but many women
decide especially once they have
children that having their children and
spending time with them is actually more
valuable than going back to the
workplace and that's a reasonable thing
to decide in fact you might think it's
the intelligent do then come back into
the workforce and they pay that's
something that you had mentioned earlier
and the fact that women pay a
disproportionate price with regards to
long term career earnings if they become
mothers that's a very narrowly focused
problem and it's a problem that might
need to be addressed but that's not the
same as the gender pay gap it's a much
more defined problem yes and part of the
problem is how do we best can we get you
to carry a benefit for that part of the
feminist tree saving not if it's part of
the feminist crusade no because that
would mean I'd have to carry a banner
for what I regard as a rather
reprehensible ideology but I do
feminism is a reference now well what
percentage of British women regard
themselves as feminists no 7% question I
would guess well know whether did the
the reasonable the reasonable
measurements of it estimate there is
something like that
it's a very small percentage yes really
it's a it's a very small minority even
if it's not 7% and part of the reason
for the - make it inherently wrong I
mean I'm not sure it's 7% and you know I
think I said we'd all go and ban
Giovanni isms but would it necessarily
be such a bad idea I mean you must have
sometimes stuck up for minority rights
even if the idea you say in your book
women are no minority by the way you're
actually a majority precisely safe so in
that sense they're not minority rights
that we're talking about here if we're
talking about women female rights have I
stuck up for minority rights I don't see
the world you've seen a 7% example would
suggest that even a small group within
women thought that feminism was it you
just decide yourself where the feminism
is a good thing or no it doesn't really
matter well I think it's not a good
thing because it plays identity politics
games and I'm not a fan of identity
critics games and the collectivist
viewpoint I don't think that men should
be set against women I don't think that
we should view the world as a
competition between men and women I
don't think we should view history as a
as a structure that pitted oppressed
women against the oppressor men I don't
like that story I think it's I think
it's a nasty story and I think it's
designed it's it's destined to divide us
in ways that will not be good I think
it's a it's a story fundamentally
predicated on resentment I don't think
it's an accurate view of the way things
unfolded in the past and I don't think
women were as powerless or as unable to
contribute as the feminist claim they
were before like 1960 you thought things
did come into balance for women in the
60s so watching her story was good about
the sixties yes I thought that the birth
control pill was invented and the reason
that women have far more flexibility
let's say in their lives now is
fundamentally because they have more
control over the reproductive status and
that never really happened until the
1960s they may have built other
conclusions on that other than that
great I can control my fertility it's
great I can control my fertility now
what is the question that what else well
that is but that but that that's exactly
it that is precisely the question that
we're dealing with but but the but the
causal order of that is oh now I can
control my fertility now what that's a
biological revolution but that has
consequences for men as well as women of
course it does and their constant watch
the men have to change we've had we've
had a lot of focus here on how women
have had it better than that perhaps you
think that feminists modern feminists
think they have I don't I don't know
need to change I don't know if women had
it better than modern feminists think
they had it I think that if women had it
hard in the past which they certainly do
that the amount of that was that was
attributable to male oppression is
small/small far smaller than the
feminists claim because Nature had her
hand in that you know the average person
in the Western world in 1895 lived on
less than a dollar a day in today's
money that's below the UN guidelines for
poverty so life was very hard for men
and women for almost all of human
history and to view that as part of an
oppression narrative on the part of men
I think is one of the things that that
is very hard on young men for example
when they're trying to take their place
in the world so what how would men have
to change because women have control
over the reproductive function that's an
open-ended question
I don't know casual sex is much more
available than it used to be that's one
way that men have been able to change
they haven't had to take on
responsibility for adopting a long-term
monogamous relationship in order to get
sexual access so that's a big change
it's also enabled men to not grow up to
quite a great I'm not sure if you're
welcoming that I'm not that I'm not I'm
not saying it's a good thing just very
concept so movements that bring you that
whole difficulty of the mating game
hookup culture into the debate must
therefore be a good thing and it
presumably you would also you know I
don't think you maybe but would you
welcome that I think there's very little
good about the hook-up culture I think
there's very little good about casual
sexual relationships I don't think
they're good for men or for women and I
mean where do you stand on the me to
campaign good thing I think that it
risks damaging the presumption of Emma's
innocence I mean there's plenty more to
it than that
oh sure women women women face the the
arbitrary admixture of sexual advance
and workplace and workplace performance
all the time it's a very complicated
thing to sort out we don't know how to
sort it out exactly because you know I
mean NBC for example the American TV
station has has made it policy that
you're not to hug your coworkers which
you know may be true although I don't
think it's the sort of thing that a
corporation might be deciding for people
but we don't know exactly what the rules
are for governing fail male and female
behavior in the workplace because we've
only been working together for about 35
years
we don't know after 35 years to figure
something out
not when you're talking about a
transformation in behavior that that's
that's that profound I mean we don't
know how men and women can work properly
together in the workforce it's very
complicated men and women across the
world but you are the ones that asked
about me too will you
with your other one hear me - is it well
me - is an expression of the fact that
men and women are having a hard time
regulating their behavior in the
workplace it's the only reason I
responded to that because the question I
think is more broadly suggesting that
some men are having a grave problem with
what is the lesson of the Harvey
Weinstein story for you someone should
have said something about Harvey
Weinstein much sooner but we could start
somewhere else we could start with
Harvey Weinstein was wrong to do what he
did before we go - yes
other people should have spoken out
second order is fair enough fair enough
I thought that went without saying there
are going to be psychopathic predators
they're going to exist and what has to
happen is that people have to stop them
because they won't stop themselves and
so I thought that was sort of implicit
in the statement obviously he shouldn't
have done what he did but you don't
think that the culture in which he was
operating that there was particularly in
his Hollywood in his world and in many
other worlds that there was a culture of
you know like this guy's a powerful guy
he's the great silverback gorilla here
let him get on with it oh I think that
culture was everywhere in Hollywood
which is why I wait
well Hollywood particularly I mean the
casting couch idea has been around for a
very long period of time and I think
that the Hollywood types who are all
upset about this should look to their
own devices with regards to the role
they played in fostering the culture
that managed that so culture we talked
we were talking about cultures so I mean
it's certainly that the Hollywood
what's the sensible thing for women to
do about me - to your mind and what's
the less sensible thing that that's a
hard question and it isn't obvious to me
exactly what men and women have to do in
the workplace to make that kind of
sexual predation much less likely with
all also subjecting themselves to
restrictions on the sexual element
aspect of their existence that would be
unbearable it's very difficult what
would be unbearable about - how about
everybody wears the same uniform to work
that's what the Mao as well look if you
want to eliminate the differences
between men and women sexually at the
workplace you have to constrain the
sexual
differences I mean men wear suits to
work we don't have to eliminate the
sexual differences for people to work
together with respect you have to
eliminate them to some degree why I'm
Jenny because you're trying to your
tribe the question here is to what
degree should sexually related behavior
be impermissible at the workplace well
it depends on how you define it should
you be able to dress attractively and if
you can dress attractively what do you
mean by attractively exactly like
precisely like organized I mean I dress
nicely today you look very well dressed
to me right your man and I'm a woman
with based nicely dressed now we're
getting on with the interview what's the
problem well the problem is is the
boundaries of what constitutes nicely
dressed because there's look because
part of what constitutes attractiveness
part of what constitutes nicely dressed
is sexual attractiveness because you
can't separate out human attractiveness
sexual attractiveness from human
attractiveness and so then the question
is exactly where are the boundaries and
that's what the discussion is about
where are the boundaries the dinner
parties to switch are described in a
foreword to your book where friends
enjoy debates and disagreements do you
think in the broader conversation we've
lost that spirit or in danger of losing
that spirit oh I think I think we're
always in danger of losing that spirit
right because lack of freedom is much
more probable than freedom we have to be
very careful to maintain that because
it's always under threat but I do feel
that it's under threat now I think that
people are very careful about what they
say in ways that aren't good I think the
fact that many comedians won't perform
on university campuses now is a very
good indication of that
that's a canary in the coalmine scenario
that but let's just stick for a moment
on kind of polarization it effects
someone like you or someone with your
message in one sense we're arguing that
polarization of society is a bad thing
if people no longer have a shared space
or shared understanding even of debates
and disagreements and nuance and yet you
part of that problem you're absolutely
the culture that up votes that down
votes in everything at the sort of
sideline on one of your after your
youtubes and there's a lot of Jordan
Peterson destroys so-and-so kills
someone yeah it seems to me a very odd
and reprehensible cut this is a
consequence of some of the way that your
argument is presented and do you feel
any responsibility there well I feel
responsibility I suppose the question is
what the question is what's that what's
the proper level of analysis let's say
well okay so first of all people are
making four thousand videos out of my
videos a week on YouTube and so we're
going to expect that there's going to be
a tremendous amount of variance and how
people do that
and they're competing for views just
like the mainstream video media is
competing for views and one of the ways
to compete for views is to become
sensationalistic and to capitalize on
polarization and I think that's a very
bad idea and I think a lot of that is
happening do you think you ever fall
into that trap ever sure I think I fall
into that trap although I wouldn't say
video well you know I because of my
distaste for what's happening on the
university campuses and my embarrassment
at being associated with with with that
because of my my academic standing let's
say I perhaps become more irritable
about the fact of of identity politics
that might be optimal although I think
in the main I'm quite careful and often
under extreme duress and I think that
that's what you have you eat fed and I
think this is a social media environment
sometimes pushes many of us in this
direction in advance what have you said
that about identity politics or possibly
when you you ended up in broad a big
argument about trans rights have you
said things that you regret it I may
have become more emotional about things
that might have been optimal in terms of
things that I've said no that's been
okay so far and I've been very careful
about what I've been saying and do you
think that people hear things the way
that you see them I just watched a lot
as you say a lot of videos been made and
they're often sort of cut
from lectures or appearances but when
you talk say about domestic violence and
there's a sort of thesis behind it and
I'm putting it in a bit bit of a
nutshell here so feel free to rephrase
it that men in the end if men are pushed
too far by a too aggressive effeminate
ism there will be a backlash and that
there is you know there's a sort of
undercurrent of violence be advised that
Sam Ordnung Nora Nora that's a warning
suggests that there may be sort of
faults in those who push progressivism
too far they will get a backlash some
people of course see that as a bit of a
permissive environment for bad behavior
well people tend to confuse describing
the likelihood of something with
supporting the fact that it exists and
I'm describing the likelihood of
something not not supporting the fact
that it exists if you push too far on
the left you're going to get a backlash
on the right that's how things work and
this is just a derivation of that as far
as I'm concerned how does that domestic
in the context of domestic violence oh I
don't I don't think it's applicable in
the context of domestic violence at all
I don't I think those things are
completely separate issues I mean you
were mentioning to me just as we were
and I was speaking only politically with
regards to the backlash that was that
that was a comment on political backlash
and it had nothing to do with domestic
violence that's a whole different issue
but violence often pops up in you in
your work or something you think drives
things that you I think you've said in
relations between men are more regulated
by a background threat of force and it's
that's that's why men have difficulty
with women is it no that's why it men
have difficulty with women who are
completely out of control but women who
show women well other women themselves
men society just like everyone is
controlled I mean you're controlled by
society I'm controlled by society and
thank God for that I mean part of funny
I mean you described yourself as a
liberal and I think a liberal doesn't
think the society controls women woman
well let's say regulates I'm a
psychologist as well a woman what is
this creature how do we know when we met
one I'm sure that you've met women in
your life that that that acted towards
you and bullying and detest
Manor it's very difficult for women to
cope with that because they don't have
any real recourse and female bullying
can be unbelievably vicious and usually
that takes the place of takes the shape
of reputation destruction innuendo and
gossip it's well documented it's very
difficult and you know men do it too but
men know it a new view oh no sir yes
when yes disproportionately women that's
what the data indicate I mean if men are
data on innuendo gossip
well it's among antisocial behavior
among adolescents it's well documented
field so because people look at
aggressive and anti-social behavior in
women and in men and in women intends to
take the expression of innuendo gossip
and reputation destruction and in mana
take tends to take the form of outright
physical aggression there's a whole
literature on that it's not a surprise
to anyone this has been known suffer for
thirty years I mean the rates of ethics
right here the female Agosta probably
predates thirty no doesn't make it
gospel but people have no it doesn't but
people have looked at how women express
it look women have to express aggression
somehow unless you're willing to say
that they're not aggressive they tend
not to do it physically not to the
degree men do so they use other channels
and what other channels are there other
than physical aggression if you're going
to be aggressive well you go after
people verbally you go after them with
innuendo and gossip and reputation
destruction and that's how it that's how
it works and just to be clear that you
think that's predominantly a female made
it so probably it isn't that I think
that it's the clinical literature
indicates that it's that I think it well
not interviewing the clinical
engineering you would use well I'm a
psychologist and a scientist and I tend
to and I tend to base my opinions on
what I've read in the broad relevant
clinical literature I'm not making this
stuff up I studied antisocial behavior
for like 15 years I'm actually quite an
expert on it and so we know that men are
more likely to look look look at it this
way all right
women are much more likely to try to
commit suicide and men are much more
likely to kill themselves and the reason
for that is that men use lethal force
and women don't now that's a big
difference okay so then you say well
women manifest aggression towards them
selves
to others but they don't use lethal
force they don't use physical force the
same way men do so they have to do it
some other way whatever way to something
some other way that people are in war
against your base your hope is Ian like
normal half and half half Hobbes half
Rousseau that's why I'm not an ideologue
because I don't think that people are
good or evil I think they're both I
don't think that culture is security or
tyranny I think it's both and I don't
think that nature is benevolence or
catastrophe I think it's both and that's
why I'm not an ideologue I need you to
cite rule now because I've got 28 bits
of paper here but I'm just gonna carry
on in the meantime because we need
getting towards the end and nicely
warmed up you rightly picked up on the
disruptive effect of social media but
also the technological shifts in in
media and mass media consumption my
argument was that this might be you know
leading to polarization the people like
you who are immensely successful within
this mill year also driving your book
sales you know you just just I think
just as I'm talking to you hit the top
of the Amazon list here in the UK but
there is that you know that the point
that you become part of the problem that
you've put a finger on yourself you want
people to get along together you want
men and women just sort of trade off we
don't agree entirely where these trade
offs are but you know we're here in
arguing about it and yet at the same
time you succeed most when you say
something very provocative that goes
viral sort of no I don't think that's
when I succeed most so for example one
of the one of the incidents that
propelled me to - just a success let's
say in terms of public recognition in
the UK was my interview with Kathy
Newman and the reason that that
propelled me to success wasn't because I
said something provocative but because I
refused under substantial duress to say
anything provocative and so the part of
the reason that I've become popular to
the degree that I have been is that I'm
actually very good at keeping my temper
under situations that would would would
not under situations where there's
substantial reason not to let's say and
I would also say that the the good that
I've done
regards to my online lectures far
outweighs whatever harm might be done by
the fact that people are cutting them
and making provocative titles out of
them and construing this as some sort of
fundamental political war but it's not
just other people if you look at
something like that the model that you
partly you know used to promote your
work is the crowdfunding site so the
more you incite a reaction the more
loyal at your patreon site the more
loyal the subscribers become now the
more money is raised for causes that you
want to promote no that isn't how it
works the reason that first of all I
give away all my content online for free
so the people who subscribe to pager and
are subscribing to nothing they're there
supporting me and then they're not
supporting me because of my political
stance primarily they're supporting me
because they've watched my videos and
they've been helped by them as
individuals and they're hoping that that
can happen to a lot of other yeah if you
want if you see the self help and you
want to give it away for nothing then
why bring money into the equation at all
and why I have this sort of high-octane
sort of it is your crowdsourcing does
rely on people coming to you wanting to
pledge their money why put money into it
at all isn't this an area where well I
think it might be better left at I am an
evil capitalist after all and I don't
really make any apologies for that I set
up my patreon site mostly out of
curiosity because I've been interested
in for a long time in how creative
people can monetize their creative
productions because that's actually part
of my technical interest because it's
very hard to monetize creative
productions because they have long term
benefit but it's hard to show why do you
want to monetize well because I can do
useful things with money and partly
because I'm curious
partly because I need to live partly
because my job was at risk for a long
while and that's not going to happen to
me again
partly because I had to give up my
clinical practice because of other
considerations
partly because I have a family partly
because I want to using money to for a
cause or is it about raising money for
you well I don't separate myself from
what I'm doing so I can't really answer
that question I mean for me what am I
going to buy a yacht no you know like
I'm not a luxury kind of guy I'm not
looking to live the high life I'm 55
years old for God's sake what would I do
with that you know I have lots of things
that I would do with with some money one
of the things I want to do is build an
online university but it's not the only
thing
want to do and so I would put the money
to good use I suspect or at least a
reasonable use and the reason that
people are providing me with this money
which they don't have to do is because
they hope that I'll continue to do what
I'm doing and that is exactly the reason
they're providing it with me and my
leftist critics have been you know been
saying for consistently it's actually
quite comical well look at all the money
that dr. Peterson is generating with his
patreon account it's like well I'm not
selling anything all the stuff I do
online is free it's not even advertising
supported so if people want to support
me on patreon because they think that
what I'm doing is helpful then like more
power to them as far as I'm concerned
and do you feel it when you the response
you get through that site and then
others that your judgment is equally
good when it comes to spotting sort of
things that gone too far and this of
can't of a far left and attitudes that
come from the right the far right all
right and I'm not mixing up these
categories with you you you can
differentiate which well do you some do
you feel that you're kind of hearing
works better in one direction than the
other ah no I don't think so I mean this
week for example I was accused by a
Jewish newspaper of harboring Nazi
sympathies which was rather miserable
but at the same time an alright article
came out today telling me that I was a
stooge and a shill for the Jews so you
know I figure I'm pretty much in the
middle if I can attract that sort of
criticism on both sides and so on with
regards to the right-wing issue the
right-wing does not pose a threat to the
integrity of universities in North
America and Europe but the left-wing
certainly does and that's well
documented and not by me there are no
conservatives in universities in the
social sciences and the humanities
they don't exist and that's not a good
thing and the radical left in
universities absolutely exists and has
throughout early threatened the
integrity of those institutions and so
to the degree that I've concentrated on
the radical left it's because the
radical left has has usurped the
universities that well might say in the
global context and authoritarianism
which often turns rightwards is a threat
to race PhD universities to the rules
absolutely and I've written extensively
about right-wing authoritarian threats
to Liberty extensively let's
let's not ignore the the the big
American elephant in the room Donald
Trump you do you see him as an
expression of a lot of the attitudes the
kind of unhappiness discontent no not
rude or something suey Jenner is
something different will make of it well
first of all you know Americans have
voted 50% Republican and 50% Democrat
for like five elections in a row nothing
changed the Republicans had Trump as a
candidate and the Democrats had Hillary
and that's the way it turned out and I
mean it was a 50/50 split so I don't see
that there's been a massive shift in the
American political landscape that's for
sure yes definitely that that's that's
that that's the that's the interesting
thing I mean Trump did something very
interesting in the primaries and and and
is in his grip on on the on the
Republican nomination eventually and I
don't know really what to make of it
it's it's certainly to some degree the
fact that he won was an expression of
the fact that people were discontented
with the Democrats tilt towards identity
politics because they lost a fair bit of
their working-class base but I think
that can be laid entirely at the feet of
the Democrats they made a big mistake
doing that because the working class
needs a political voice and the
Democrats decided to play identity
politics so he blamed them is anything
wrong with with Trump or anything is
wrong with Trump you know I mean it
doesn't take a genius to lay them out
while he's rather bombastic he seems to
be somewhat on the narcissistic side
he's certainly a master at manipulating
the media I mean so it and and and he's
a very peculiar character it doesn't
take a genius to list his faults what
Trump signifies I I don't know I can't I
can't put my finger on him yet let's
conclude with I don't think he's a great
coming of Satan you know I don't think
that the America is any more polarized
than it was in 1972 and and the economy
in the u.s. is booming at the moment and
he hasn't got us into any particularly
idiotic Wars yet so I'm pretty happy
about that liberalism what needs it what
they need to change you said earlier on
that you were casting it really it's
hustled a bit about what that might mean
in terms of what causes you supporter
used to dissociate itself from the
radical left which it refuses to do it
won't undertake the conceptual
difficulty of deciding when the left has
gone too far and I've got to ask you
have you got a favorite feminists do I
have a favorite feminist I don't think
of things that way I'm not a favorite
video logs do I have a favorite
admirable woman who would be my favorite
admirable woman I'm sorry I have a
difficulty difficult time bringing names
to mind the woman who established
nursing as a profession in Britain it's
nice yes Florence Nightingale it's like
it's good for Florence
she thought I think men were unsuited to
Nursing because she she had gender
stereotypes should we be telling her off
well some men are unsuited to Nursing
and some aren't and unlikely any
unlikely heroes or heroines I'm a big
fan of Tom Waits
don't Waits I think we can agree on that
Jordan Peterson thank you very much
thanks a lot for the invitation
you